we need to factor negative 40 squared
minus 12t
minus 9 and a good place to start just
say well are there any common factors
for all of these terms when you look at
them well these first two are divisible
by 4 these last two are divisible by 3
but not all of them are divisible by any
one number well but you could factor out
a negative one but even if you factor
out a negative one so you say this is
the same thing as negative 1 times
positive 4 T squared plus twelve T plus
9 you still end up with a non-one
coefficient out here and on the second
degree term on the T squared term so you
might want to immediately start grouping
this and if you did group if you did
factor it by grouping it would work you
would get the right answer but there is
something you might be able to or there
is something about this equation that
might pop at it out of you that might
make it a little bit simpler to solve
and to understand that let's take a
little bit of a of a of a break here on
the right hand side and just think about
what happens if you take a plus B times
a plus B if you just have you know a
binomial squared well you have a times a
which is a squared then you have a times
that B which is plus a B then you have B
times a which is the same thing as a B
and then you have B times B or you have
B squared and so if you add these middle
two terms right here you're left with a
squared plus 2 a B plus B squared this
is the square of a binomial
now does this right here does 40 squared
plus 12t plus 9 fit this pattern
well the 40 squared is a squared so if
this right here is a squared if that is
a squared right there then what does a
have to be if this is a squared then a
would be equal to the square root of
this it would be 2t and if this is B
squared let me do that in a different
color if if this right here is B squared
if the 9 is B squared right there then
that means that B is equal to 3 it's
equal to the positive square root
of the nine now this number right here
and actually doesn't have to just be
equal to three it might have been
negative 3 as well it could be plus or
minus 3 but this number here is it two
times a B right that's the middle term
that we care about is it two times a B
well if we multiply 2t times three we
get 60 and then we multiply that times
two you get twelve T this right here
twelve T is equal to two times 2t times
three it is two times a B and if this
was a negative three we would look to
see if this was a negative twelve but
this does work for a positive three so
this does fit the pattern of a perfect
squared this is a this is a special type
of ways you could do this is a square of
a binomial so if you wanted to factor
this the stuff on the inside you still
have that negative one out there the 4t
squared plus 12t plus nine you could
immediately say well that's going to be
a plus B times a plus B or or two T to T
plus three two T plus three times 2t
plus three or you could just say it's 2t
plus three squared it fits this pattern
and of course you can't forget about
this negative one out here you could
have also solved it by grouping but this
might be a quicker thing to recognize
this is a number squared that's another
number squared if you take each of those
numbers that you're squaring take their
product and multiply it by two you have
that right there so this is a perfect
square